here's a
quadrilateral how do we find the sum of
angles of this
quadrilateral let's name the
quadrilateral first let's call it a b c
d we have to find the sum of angles of
the quadrilateral a b c d it's simple
the sum of angles is the measure of
angle a plus angle B plus angle C plus
angle
D yes that's correct but we haven't been
given any of the measures now what what
do we do next since we are familiar with
triangles let us break the figure into
two
triangles let's join points A and C like
this but wait how does this help us
let's try to write the sum in a
different way angle a will be the sum of
these two angles it means angle angle a
can be written as angle D A Plus angle c
a angle B is not split so we write it as
is angle c will equal the sum of these
two angles it can be written as angle
BCA plus angle
ACD the angle D is written as is do you
think we getting closer to the answer
yes you can now see that we can join the
angles of each triangle
together these three angles belong to
this triangle and these three belong to
this one we can write the first group as
angle da a plus angle ACD plus angle D
it is the sum of the angles of triangle
ACD and the second group can be written
as angle BCA plus angle B plus angle
cab and since the sum of interior angles
of a triangle angle is
180° this expression will equal
180° and this expression as well will
equal
180° the sum equals
360° so the sum of interior angles of a
quadrilateral equals
[Music]
360°